Well,
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the meet in the middle of the
sandwich.
My first thing is to say,
please turn off your mobile phones
because it was always someone who
forgets we get a bit of old or Beethoven
or they're not hearing tune.
It's very distracting.
Secondly,
make sure you don't lose these in the
course of the debate because you're
going to need them to vote at the end,
nor should you tear them in half because
if you are going to vote,
don't know.
You need to put those in together or
looking forward to a very lively
interchange from the between the panel
on the floor,
so sharpen your wits and make notes of
anything you find that is either
particularly excellent you want to
amplify or particularly annoying that
you want to rebut.
Your time will come.
You can read,
not going to say,
well,
that was a consequence of the empire or
not.
You're going to read so I'm not going to
give very long biographies.
I should just introduce the speakers.
I'm very briefly,
but I would urge you please to buy all
the books on sale outside.
They all make ideal Christmas presents
and um,
it's the best.
The nicest thing for the speaker after
the emotion,
even if they haven't,
one,
is to be besieged by people saying,
please can you sign this copy of the
book or even better copies of the book.
The emotion,
um,
is Britain's former colonies should stop
blaming the empire for their ills.
And one can debate that a little bit in
terms of the terms.
What exactly do we mean by our colony is
a Scotland commonly is arland economy is
corn will accompany.
France might used to be British at one
point,
or at least bits of it.